the conservation department treats rare
books documents and artworks from all of
Columbia's special collections the staff
includes three professional conservators
who bring specialized training to their
work of treating some of the library's
most valuable holdings the conservators
combine traditional craft skills with
knowledge of new technology and current
scientific research to help in the work
of caring for Columbia's artifacts the
library's laboratory provides modern
equipment such as the microscope this
conservator is using to examine the
paint layers of a medieval manuscript as
well as tools and supplies that would be
familiar to a bookbinder of the 16th
century we'll look at some examples of
treatments frequently performed in
Columbia's lab this drawing on fragile
tracing paper arrived with tears and old
adhesive tape conservators mend tears in
artworks and documents using handmade
paper the paper's special long fibers
strengthen the area around a tear
it is applied with a natural adhesive
that can be reversed in water the
conservator carefully monitors the
moisture in the paste and uses blotting
paper to control how the men dries
depending upon the condition of the
document this work can take minutes or
many hours the leaves of a book may be
removed from their binding to be washed
if the condition of the paper is very
poor
washing is done in purified and pH
balanced water using sheets of webbing
to support the wet leaves in the bath
historic papers may be acidic due to
their manufacture and poor storage in
past centuries this acidity can cause
paper to break down and become brittle
in the bath products of acidic reactions
are washed away resulting in a cleaner
and more permanent sheet after washing
compared to an unwashed sheet this
treatment improves the chemical
stability of the paper as well as the
appearance conservators test inks
carefully before washing in this case
the ink from a stamp would have bled in
the bath so it is masked with clear film
to protect it while the rest of the leaf
is washed on a suction table the suction
pulls water from the damp blotting paper
directly through the book leaf and
prevents it moving into the area of the
staff these book leaves are sewn as book
binders have done since the Middle Ages
the natural linen sewing thread is
passed through the folds of paper and
around tensioned linen cords on a sewing
frame conservators must identify
evidence to be preserved such as this
folded corner which indicates the size
of the original sheet of paper used to
print this book the conservator judges
the thickness of thread to use when
sewing since this controls the shape of
the finished book once it is bound when
a book lacks a suitable cover the
conservator will rebind it for this
treatment the most appropriate style for
the new binding was a full leather cover
made with specially tanned leather the
leather edges are paired with a
razor-sharp knife and the conservator
judges how much to thin the skin to suit
the size of the book using a tool called
a spokeshave she has modified for
leather work
when the paste is applied to the leather
it becomes damp and malleable then the
leather is applied to the book working
it carefully around the board edges and
the head caps so that the finished
binding will function well rebinding a
rare book requires judgment of the
correct historic style for the new
binding to carry out their treatment
enhancing the books durability and
improving its function like a machine
since moving parts must be sized and
fitted correctly every aspect of the
binding is executed by the conservator
to work properly when the book is opened
once the leather is well adhered the
conservator ties it up around the bands
to dry this ensures good adhesion when
the book is opened for reading with
their technical skills and knowledge of
material science and the history of
books and artworks supported by the
resources of the conservation laboratory
and its specialized equipment Colombia's
conservators ensure that the library's
collections will be well preserved and
remain accessible by scholars today as
well as in the future
you